I'm going to talk about some of my favorite people today.
Uh,
over the weekend I was at a memorial service and,
uh,
a conference in honor of my late mentor,
I,
the great historian and sociologist Charles Tilly.
And when I first knew him,
which was a long time ago,
uh,
he was working on a,
on collective violence.
He's someone in his career who published literally 51 books over 600 articles,
but above all was a generous mentor to a whole bunch of people,
including yours truly.
But he was working on collective violence.
And,
um,
he once told me,
in fact,
I couldn't find exactly where he wrote this if he did.
Um,
he once told me,
and I mentioned this the first day,
but that it's bitter hard to write the history of remainders.
And so some of the people that I'm going to talk about today didn't see
themselves as remainders in history,
but there are people who didn't quite fit in and,
and,
um,
we're really overwhelmed and ultimately defeated by the economic and social and
political processes.
And if one of the themes of this course,
and if any course really,
I suppose in the deals with the modern,
uh,
a world experience,
even in,
especially in this day as of globalization,
Oh,
is that,
that dynamic dual of a capitalism or large scale economic change,
uh,
and the state,
you're going to see that today in,
in some of the folks that I'm,
uh,
I'm talking about.
And I once used the example of trying to get you to imagine,
you know,
parachuting over the European continent over very slow descent and the,
let's say now from maybe Oh,
mid 16th century,
until mid 19th century.
And if,
um,
you could see every incident of collective violence,
of political protest,
popular protest that occurred,
uh,
and,
and all protest is ultimately a political,
uh,
by far the most prevalent would have been the grain riot.
And this itself is terribly significant.
And so as his disappearance,
given what I've just said about,
about the state and large scale economic change,
another way to imagine this is if you had,
um,
a Richter scale,
uh,
that,
you know,
that move or that registered every incident of collective violence until he and
his whole team,
uh,
we're counting up every single incident of collective violence that they could
find in Europe between,
uh,
really mid 18th century.
And in terms of his study or even earlier than that in 1936 and would come to
the same conclusion that you would wear you floating over,
uh,
this great continent for that period of time.
And so what I'm going to do today is it sort of a trilogy talk about,
um,
uh,
three things,
first grain riots and they're all related.
Second,
the swing movement,
Captain Swing drawing on the book,
a classic book a long time ago of,
of Eric Cobb's bomb and George were day to truly great historians along with
Tilly and third,
talk about something that I did.
Uh,
uh,
talk about the demos l of the Ahi Edge.
And I'll make that clear in a while.
But all three fit together,
I think very nicely.
And,
uh,
one of the underlying themes which you'll see is that that popular protest and
collective violence attached to popular protest,
uh,
is not random,
or,
uh,
well,
it's spontaneous,
can be spontaneous,
but it's not illogical that there's a logic to popular protest,
uh,
right through the ages,
in the early modern period as well as in the 19th century.
And that,
uh,
that ordinary people put forth their demands,
by protesting and in doing so hope to,
to,
uh,
to affect change,
to,
to appeal to authorities who hopefully will do the right thing and often imagine
a world in the past where,
um,
where we're a sense of justice prevailed.
And in terms of,
of grain riots,
I'll talk about the just price because they talked about it.
Um,
so having said that,
let me enter the world of,
of,
of grain riots.
Um,
give you some examples.
This is from Spain,
1856 with the pretext of the high price of bread and for lack of work,
uh,
the workers.
I've followed the lead and uh,
and Burgos rose and burn flower stores,
mills in inspection offices,
the civil,
the civil governor intervene to put down the rising,
but the rebels overwhelmed him and attack the chiefs of his forces.
The sacking and burning continued most likely as a consequence of the spreading
of news of the incident disturbance is also spread to the countryside and to
other cities.
The governor of Palencia tried to hold back the uprising and his city,
but he had to retreat before a hissing crowd and Ben Avant Day,
uh,
Rio Seco and along the Casti,
um,
a canal.
The disorders reoccurred.
Yeah,
the characteristics of the old type of rebellion aimed at spectators and
hoarders among whom the Ma,
the masters of workshops were counted in their hatred.
The insurgents set fire to shops and store houses with the cry of chief Brett
cheap bread,
and attack the boats that serve for the transport of grain as well as putting
the torch to grain.
Not yet harvested in the fields.
If you back up almost a century ago in France,
if you look at the memo,
the memoirs of,
of uh,
of a,
a royal official,
um,
if,
if for May 3rd eye in the seven in 1775,
the musketeers who had been worn the day before,
hurry to the markets,
the fleeing rioters overturned baskets full of bread and block the way to the
horses.
It was 9:00 AM the watch was supposed to be getting its orders at that hour.
And the people that are already gone to the bakers and sees the bread they found
in the shops,
the pit that pillage had a special character.
People did it without violence.
The shops of the bakers were emptied and those of the pastry makers and the
dealers and other foods which were equally exposed,
we're left untouched.
Um,
or 1816 in England,
east Anglia,
um,
in early summer,
uh,
surprise came that the agricultural laborers who will come back to hear about in
a little while of east Anglia had come out and revolt conditions had worsened
since the end of the Napoleonic war and riots and disturbances were everywhere,
uh,
in the towns,
um,
well,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
The point is that I,
I could give you,
uh,
examples from virtually every country over a very long period of time.
And the grain riot would,
um,
would dominate.
Now if you took just,
well,
if you take,
if you take this is France based,
but it's true of almost everywhere.
Uh,
and again,
do not write this down.
Men Fight for food in the following years,
particularly,
they come in waves.
1693,
94,
98,
seven,
10 oh nine,
10 17,
28,
1739,
40 49,
50 to 68,
70 1775,
big one.
1785 1788 899399181118 21816181718 291830183940 84647185354 and then never
again.
I never again,
I mean in France,
never again.
And slowly the grain riot disappears as a form of political protest of
collective violence or collective nonviolence depending on the case.
And so that's,
that's the big question is you know what,
what's going on here.
You know,
popular protest is a way of finding out what's going on when you look at all
this stuff.
And why do the grain riots disappear as a form of collective violence?
Why?
Here's a placard that is a,
you know,
a poster scrawled in the town of [inaudible] in the west of France in 1709,
uh,
we are dying of hunger.
We must absolutely order you to set prices on bread and grain or else we will
break from our homes like enraged lions,
weapons in one hand,
fire in the other.
Arson fire,
by the way,
is,
is one of those with my friend Jim Scott at Yale,
uh,
calls weapons of the weak,
you know,
just a match to a harvest or to a roof.
A show me,
yeah.
Uh,
you know,
of,
of a,
of a thatched cottage,
uh,
can,
can do some serious mischief,
but what they want to do,
these grain rioters,
very ordinary people,
men and particularly women.
Remember,
women are responsible for the household economy and also young people.
And also children.
What they want to do is they're putting forth claims.
They want the government,
the monarchies,
the administrators,
the officials,
the aunt on dawn,
the governors,
the rural,
the sheriffs in England to set the price of bread as Maximillian of hope was
piano.
And there's Jacobi.
I had wanted them to,
why?
To set the price of bread to keep the price of bread low so that everybody would
have access to,
uh,
to buying bread.
Now,
bread represent bread.
Literally that commodity,
whether dark bread in the,
in,
in the poor regions of central Europe,
uh,
or in the south of France or in parts of Spain and southern Italy or white
bread,
which is more associated with more prosperous peasants,
represented more than half of,
of the expenses of ordinary people,
not just food but bread.
So bread is what people,
a black bread where the poorer areas,
white bread,
uh,
the wealthier areas to make a generalization,
there are all different kinds of bread.
Um,
and so well,
here's how I can approach this in the town of on the edge,
uh,
which is in,
in well Onia that is in that what's now eastern Belgium,
uh,
Les [inaudible],
a famous words cork like other things.
Um,
and now part of the rust belt of,
of eastern Belgium,
they had a municipal statute that is a municipal regulation,
uh,
from about the 14th century.
The date 1317 sticks in my mind somewhere.
I must've read that decades ago.
And it said that on market day that merchants would not be allowed from other
places,
would not be allowed in to buy grain until the third day of the market.
And by the way,
the term for merchants,
they use where own grocer,
which has a sense in French of people who would make themselves fat on closer,
um,
why?
Because they could afford to buy bread at the price that nobody else could
afford and they wouldn't be allowed until the third day of the market.
But of course,
uh,
that's not what happens through most of European history.
And so the pressure from these crowds,
the logic of these crowds is too forced municipal authorities in the name of
order,
but perhaps who knows,
and the name of justice to set a price of bread so that everybody could have a
shot at it.
Now,
with some wag ones put,
you know,
criticizing this kind of social history.
Well,
it's pretty obvious that grain riots occur on market days,
uh,
in areas in which there is grain being exported out of a region.
But that is precisely the point.
And so the,
the peasants don't,
and or towns,
people don't riot.
Ordinary people don't riot,
uh,
necessarily when,
you know,
the price of grain reaches its absolute maximum.
But when they,
when they riot is they,
they riot the seas grain,
uh,
or they pillage shops at the moment when particularly when they see grain being
taken out of the community,
removed from their sense of moral authority over something upon which they
depend,
uh,
to live.
And so,
uh,
women as I said before,
played a major part,
the major role in grain rights.
Why?
Because they're responsible for the household economy.
And so right through this whole period,
there's a familiar scenario.
People,
uh,
poor into town for market day,
they see the stage coaches to did the Jones,
the wagons carding the gray in a way and they stop,
they stop.
And it's the same format everywhere is if you had some sort of internet or CNN
or some thing like that telling people here's how you grain riot.
But they don't rip off the grain and they don't rip off is the one example that
I gave you.
Fancy pastries and stuff like that.
They take the grain often to a communal piece of property such as the Commons or
a municipal,
the well or,
or,
or the,
the shed.
The,
the,
uh,
I mean the,
the covered market.
I mean,
somebody was fantastic examples,
you know,
uh,
are,
are in the south of France,
but all sorts of places too.
And they sell the grain to ordinary people at what they consider to be the just
price.
And they use that expression to just price.
And there's a sense of moral outrage that some forces they can't control are
taking away what they need to survive.
1789 a year.
You know,
what's the,
what's the big collective action in Paris?
It's the seizing of the busty of course.
But above all is the attack on the customs barriers.
The tax offices that ring Paris,
which forced the price of food,
grain bread,
everything up higher.
They attack them as a symbol of what they consider to be an unfair economy
that's depriving them of the right to have enough to eat.
Now,
so these,
but these wagons,
you know,
that are carrying grain away.
Who's in these wagons?
Who are these folks and where are they doing?
Well,
their merchants.
And they know that if they can take them and they're buying up grain,
where are they taking the grain?
They're taking it to Berlin or they're taking it to Stuttgart where they're
taking it to Munich or to Milan or to Paris or Lee.
Y'All.
Why?
Because that grain will command even a higher price there when you've got all
these people.
And what is the interest of monarchies and other forms of,
of,
of tyranny,
if you will.
It's the ancestors to feed the city's first.
And so the growth of cities,
the growth of bureaucracies of the state,
the growth of garrisons,
we have to be fed,
increases the pressure on,
uh,
on,
on grain in times of,
of,
of harvest failure and grain riots.
You know,
not only are the timing is,
you know,
market's wood grain is leaving the town,
but of course,
obviously the subtext is that at times of these cyclical harvest failures,
the harvest fails.
Credit is withdrawn.
Uh,
the price of bread goes up and the riots start.
And if you look at where the riots started,
any of these countries that I've talked about,
uh,
they are,
it's in response to these two grain being taken out of rural regions and being
taken to cities to get higher prices.
So you've got the merchant on the wagon to,
and you probably got his driver,
but who else do you have?
They're increasingly,
well,
you've got,
you've got the Gardasil Vila in,
in Spain are,
you've got to,
you've got the,
uh,
you know,
various police in the Italian,
uh,
states are,
you've got the,
uh,
tough hardened a Berlin police or the,
you know,
the Prussian army or you've got the gendarme or the mile she'll say is they
called them.
I show mommy show,
say as they called them in the 18th century.
Or there's gendarme in the 19th century.
So here again,
here's a way of looking at this theme of the state and capitalism or on the
wagon here you've got the merchant and you've got the police guarding him.
That's the dynamic dual of change over the long run.
So you know,
the,
to be sure people who per,
who have big plots of land,
uh,
in Pomerania a or in northern Italy,
or in the bullets,
uh,
you know,
the south of Paris or on shots or someplace like that.
Uh,
you know,
these are big,
these people are,
I'm not out grain rioting.
What,
what are they doing?
They're hoarding.
They're waiting till the price of grain even goes higher.
And that's why form of popular of collective action in all throughout this whole
period,
our tax on hoarders,
you know,
1789,
you read about it in the book,
the famine plot,
the idea that somehow,
you know,
that wealthy aristocrats or trying to starve out the poor to get their way,
and then a hoarder's have a huge just sacks of grain,
which they often did in their chateaus and that they're calling it from the
market.
And Laissez Faire says,
let the market decide the price will,
okay,
let's keep that stuff back.
People go hungry too damn bad for them.
They should have more money
over and over and over again.
In all of these places.
The grain riot is,
that is the most important form of,
of collective violence,
of popular protest.
And then it just disappears.
Again.
France is the most studied,
but it disappears earlier in Britain.
You'll,
you'll know why already,
you already know.
I'll tell you again in a minute.
Ain't no peasants left in Britain.
Okay.
When France,
the last wave is 1855.
Now there are protests at the end of the 19th century against the high cost of
food.
Uh,
the,
these are,
you know,
one shouldn't imagine when people,
I don't know,
surrounding the stop and shop with a blocking it with,
with,
uh,
you know,
with,
with their little pushcarts that they're,
they're,
they're putting their frozen food into.
Uh,
but there are the equivalent of a,
of that.
I mean,
there are protests against the high cost of food and food still.
Uh,
W is an important dynamic in,
in,
in protest.
And we'll work to,
for example,
you know,
irritation about,
about,
uh,
the,
the rich doing even better than,
than,
than ever.
And in rationing,
rationing cards and all that business,
but the food,
but the grain,
right simply disappears as a form of popular protest in Europe period.
It doesn't mean that bread wouldn't be terribly important.
And in the Russian revolution it does.
And there are,
you know,
there are riots in,
in Russia,
uh,
you know,
against the height,
high price of,
of,
uh,
of bread.
But the classic from Western Europe,
beginning of Western Europe and moving east,
the classic,
just the quintessentially popular domain of protest,
expression of popular protest just disappears.
Period.
Plot,
why the battle's been won,
the merchants,
the police,
the gendarme,
the troops,
they've already there.
And,
and,
and beginning again,
West Eastern Europe,
you've got the d population of,
of marginal rural property,
uh,
marginal rural lands,
people can't make it any more,
producing little bits of this and that.
And they,
uh,
pledge themselves in to the new urban,
emerging new,
or not new,
but a ever increasing urban world.
Uh,
in order to find a find work.
And so if you look at what people protest over,
we can see that,
you know,
you can see this big economic change.
I mean,
the 19th century just transforms the way people live this of sure as the 19th
century.
It didn't invent consumer culture.
We already know Yonda reasons just published within the last month or two or
just to,
you know,
a brilliant book about,
about showing that that ordinary families,
uh,
made all sorts of sacrifices to try to improve their lives beginning in the
middle of the,
of the 17th century,
participating in this consumer culture,
buying soap,
buying forks and,
and that kind of thing.
Uh,
but these big,
big time economic changes,
the 19th century is really,
uh,
is,
is the crucial period in the whole thing.
And the disappearance of the grain riot as a form of,
uh,
popular protest is just,
you know,
a fantastic,
uh,
a demonstration of that fact.
You know,
you don't want to complicate the thing or,
or,
or really undermine the validity of what I was said by imagining.
Say,
well,
that's all pre modern.
You know,
this kind of protest and we've got our modern protests and you know,
it's an more strikes and all that.
It's true that they're more strikes and strikes become,
uh,
you know,
another sort of classic form of political protest.
But,
uh,
but the world of the 19th century was changing and,
you know,
the big losers in all of this of course,
are a rural people,
rural labors,
uh,
peasants who simply couldn't make a go,
and uh,
and,
uh,
their world is transformed.
That's the part one of this trilogy.
Secondly,
and I'll,
let's look at the swing movement.
These next two things I'm going to talk about.
Um,
yeah,
yeah.
Our,
uh,
take place really at the same time.
And that's not a coincidence.
It's not a coincidence at all.
The first story is that of captain swing.
I alluded to this the very first day if those who were here,
um,
was,
uh,
18,
29,
really 1830,
uh,
those are the big years.
And then the demo is out of the Ahi Edge,
um,
comes to just the same time.
There are similar,
fascinating.
I think they're fascinating.
I hope you will too.
Uh,
and they have so much in common with each other and what I've just been talking
about.
It's not about winners and losers in the brave new economy of,
of,
uh,
of a high powered capitalism and all its incarnations,
in,
in Europe,
big and small.
Uh,
but it's,
it's,
um,
we see the faces,
uh,
the remainders of this kind of economic change.
And again,
this is the people who worked on captain swing or George Rudy and a and Eric
Hobsbawm.
Um,
how to put this
in.
There was a real person called Ned Lud in about 18,
16,
18 in there in England.
Uh,
Lud the word English word Luddite is someone who is a machine breaker.
Luddism is machine breaking.
You break the machines because machines are putting you out of work.
You're a handloom weaver,
famous cases in Silesian in Germany and then machine is there.
Glassworks later in the century.
Things I taught,
I've talked about last time.
We're putting them out of work.
And Ned Lud busted up machines.
He broke the machine.
18,
29.
Awful economic year everywhere in Europe,
freezing winter hunger,
real hunger in Britain.
That's my example from Britain,
from England,
specifically from the south of England.
Even more specifically,
they found people who are starved to death in the fields with only dandelions in
their stomachs with nothing else to eat.
If you were a freshman or a German or an Italian,
say northern Italian and you went to England in 1829 or 1830 if you did the
reverse of the Arthur Young track,
Arthur Young was always wandering through France and discovering people he
thought were 65 or 70 turned out there were 29 there were so battered and beaten
down by by hardship.
They're famous case of a woman he met in Sham Fanya near ass of the of that
case.
Arthur Young saw all of these peasants in Europe,
but the counterpart of Arthur Young people from the continent going to England,
we're amazed there weren't any more pessimists,
virtually no peasants.
If you'd find a peasant as a small property owner,
existentially committed to the land that's a little bit overly fancy,
but dependent upon a small piece of land,
a low power to tear off a piece of land,
uh,
for uh,
family survival.
The household economy.
Um,
there,
there weren't any more peasants left in England.
What there were,
where you had gentry,
you had big property owners who are masters of all that they saw before them in
the portraits they had painted of themselves.
You had gentry,
you had yeoman who were smaller versions of gentry.
Uh,
you had,
uh,
you know,
property owners or middle rank pop property owners and this sort of thing.
You had wealthy people from the city buying,
wanting to live in an aristocratic way.
Blang as much land as they could take.
There was no place in Europe in which such a small percentage of the population
owns so much of the land.
That's still true today in,
in Britain.
Still true today.
But there weren't any peasants.
Why?
Because the big fish had eaten the smaller fish.
And because beginning of the 16th century,
the enclosure movement,
which you've read about,
I think the enclosure movement meant that basically no surprise the big guys get
the law on their side.
Parliament passes thousands of acts of enclosure,
which allow people to enclose and divide up the common land and the big fish eat
the smaller fish.
And the peasantry is basically uh,
uh,
destroyed.
And so what you have,
as I said before,
in another context in England,
you've got all sorts of textile workers.
You've got all sorts of governances and domestic workers and you have hundreds
of thousands,
millions of agricultural laborers.
You have agricultural laborers and other countries too.
But you also have small property owners.
Hardly any of those folks left in England.
So to return to the story in 1829,
they start ordinary people start participating in protest and collective action
and they start threatening and indeed smashing and burning threshing machines.
Why threshing machines?
Cause threshing machines are taking their work.
What they,
the way they survived was during harvest.
They go from place to place,
working the way people still doing the wine harvest and south of France,
uh,
working from place to place,
bringing in the harvest,
prosperous agricultural land in the south of England.
This is how they get by.
They don't live very well.
They don't do very well,
but they're large.
They're fed.
They have a crummy place to sleep,
but they can do okay.
But then the big guys,
the big farmers,
they start,
they start buying threshing machines.
So the threshing machines do the work in these people.
So the next time the guys come along,
you know,
I'm into groups of 10,
20,
30 families,
pals,
friends,
they come around and say,
well look,
you know,
uh,
it's harvest time.
Here we are.
Nuvola uh,
sorry,
old chap.
We don't need you.
Maybe a couple of you,
but we don't need you.
We've got these machines.
They do the job that you used to do.
We don't have a problem with them working hard all the time.
The machines work all the time at our command.
Sia
Are they mad?
They're furious and they start burning these machines.
They start smashing down the gates and going in and burning these machines.
And then they started to find,
they started to find,
uh,
posters that had been written scrawled posters,
sometimes barely literate cause this when that wasn't illiterate literate
population.
And they begin to talk about a mythical like figure like Ned Lud except this
wasn't a real one and my favor,
I just,
former girlfriend longtime ago it mighty Michigan and we were going to write a
screenplay about this.
We never did.
One of them has said that,
they all said like,
if you don't rid of the threshing machine,
your agony will begin.
We will destroy your machines,
we will burn you out.
But the best that I ever saw was revenge for the is on the wing from thy
determined captain swing who was captain swing.
He was a sense of popular justice.
He was what used to be called the moral economy.
He did not exist.
He should have.
He's still,
he's still should exist.
He did not exist.
But captain swing gave this kind of paramilitary sense too.
We are many.
We are correct.
We are right.
We have God.
On our side,
we are organized and we will win.
The subtext is that maybe we let her negotiate and see,
maybe you keep few machines around,
but we want our jobs back.
So captain swing,
he was everywhere.
He was in Kent,
he was in Cambridge.
Cambridgeshire,
he was in Devon,
he was in wheelchair.
He didn't exist,
but he was everywhere,
at least in the popular imagination.
By the way,
the captain swing folks had some allies and they were the small,
smaller farmers who couldn't afford the big time threshing machines.
And they thought,
well,
you know,
maybe if they,
if they burn the machines of my,
uh,
ravenous neighbor,
that wouldn't be the worst thing in the world.
So they get a little kind of moral support from folks like that and they spread
and they're there.
They're in all sorts of places.
Do they win?
Are you kidding?
They lose.
The sheriff comes and in a country that didn't like that,
only had a police force starting in 18,
29 in London,
that didn't like the idea of uniformed armies.
That was something the French and the Spanish had.
Uh,
they,
they start,
they bring their military contingents and they beat the hell out of these people
and they put them on trial.
They hang some of them,
not all that money.
They send lots of them to where to Tasmania,
that's where they sent them.
Or to Australia.
We all live in a convent colony,
as they say,
sometimes thing in Australia when they really play the palms,
as they call the British,
uh,
they send them a long,
long way and they defeat them.
It's bitter hard to write the history of remainders.
It's fun though too.
It's fun.
Captains swing disappears.
The big guys win
enclosure keeps,
keeps rolling along.
Tens of thousands of people are on the road.
Oh,
they get a little victory.
The poor law of 1832 is probably influenced by,
by this threat,
this perceived threat of popular people voting with their feet
threatening,
but also negotiating conjolling trying to imagine a time in the past when
everybody had a shot at doing well enough.
Same thing.
That's the grain riots.
Imagining a time when there was a just price for everything.
Captain Swing was really part of that.
Uh,
you know,
obviously Aikido,
I find what they did thrilling,
but I probably shouldn't say that.
Um,
and of course they probably had a lot of time to think about what they did on
that day,
extraordinarily long a trip to Port Arthur and not the port Arthur in Asia,
but the port author Arthur in,
uh,
in Tasmania a or to what would become new South South Wales or Victoria in
Australia.
But Catherine swing a disappeared.
He never existed,
but he sure should have.
Now,
long time ago when I was starting out,
um,
I was working in the archives,
invests in a,
you know,
in Paris or on the edge of Paris,
the military archives there,
and the big chefs would events then,
and I was working on,
I was working on other stuff and I kept finding these incidents that were
occurring at precisely the same time as captain swing 18,
29,
1830,
not in England,
but in France.
And I kept finding these reports from,
uh,
from a,
a part of,
uh,
oh.
And I didn't bring a map and I can't draw with a damn either.
Um,
yeah.
All right.
Okay.
Well but,
but that,
that the to imagine labelle foss.
I,
here we go.
Nice.
Huh?
Um,
mountains,
pepe,
annual to lose here.
Uh,
Boldo up here.
What a,
um,
I kept finding in a department called the [inaudible] edge mountainous
department.
I kept finding these reports,
the capital of his flaw,
but that's in the plane kind of,
and then you go up into the mountains and you've got real serious mountains and
now people drive through those mountains to get down door to buy cheaper posties
and cigarettes and that kind of thing.
But it is very,
very beautiful there.
It's full also now of people from 1968 and went off and formed communes and the,
and the,
and the Ahi Edge.
And sometimes you see some of them staggering around there.
But I kept finding reports of,
uh,
but from the police,
or from the gendarme above all or from mayors saying that men dressed as women
were coming down the mountain in the mist and the,
and the snow.
Armed with pitchforks armed with rifles.
And we're chasing away two groups of people,
Shop Boone,
Yay.
Who are charcoal burners,
forest people cutting down trees and forest guards,
those people guarding the forest
employed by the state,
employed by the rural bourgeoisie or people living in Florida or to news who
owned a lot of people on a lot of land in the forest.
Uh,
or by uh,
uh,
you know,
by communes if it's forest.
Uh,
we're a communally owned to try to keep out ordinary people and these people
were coming down the mountain and taking shots at them and yelling nasty things
to them,
threatening them with pitch forks and tried to drive them away.
And then they would find notes saying if the forest guards and the charcoal
burners come back,
your agony,
we'll begin signed.
Jean Lieutenant of the dem was out,
a demo was l and franchise obviously,
you know,
a young woman then was added and these became known as the dumb was l of the
edge.
So I found so many of these in 18,
29,
1830,
1831,
a few in 1848,
a couple in 1872 and never again,
never again.
Who are these people and what were they doing?
What they wanted.
Again,
think of captain swing.
Think of the grain writes.
What they wanted was the access to the forest.
They'd always had access to the forest.
It's cold in the [inaudible] edge.
You need wood that's gleaned from the forest to make fires,
to stay alive.
You need berries,
roots to eat.
You need places to pasture your animals.
Pigs,
which you know,
eat right down through the root goats like we have in,
in,
in our village,
in the south and all dash,
uh,
or you know,
sheep if are really rich,
maybe cows,
but that didn't happen very much there.
Uh,
the rich guys will own the cows.
The peasants didn't,
knowing the cows they'd always for centuries as they well remembered,
had access to,
to the forest.
Why do they lose access to the forest?
They're looking back at an imaginary time and they,
well,
it wasn't imaginer.
They always had had access.
There was a lots of forests.
The whole place.
Deforestation is a big problem in France since the 17th,
18th century.
But the peer knees have many forests,
many mountains.
They'd always been able to go there as they wanted.
They didn't own the forest,
but use and property.
We're not categories that were,
that meant anything to anyone.
And they're told they can't go there anymore.
So some of them would go to churches and they're looking for deeds that would
have given their village people those villages rights to be in the forest
centuries ago.
No,
they don't find him.
So why can't think of the forest anymore to pasture they're miserable animals or
to find something to eat or some fuel.
Why can't they do that anymore?
Uh Ha.
Talking capitalism in the state,
the price of wood is increased.
Why the metallurgical industry,
what they call catalogs as in Catalonia Forges Frg.
Yes.
Forges small metallurgical industries.
The price of wood goes up.
So suddenly the people that own the forest say,
hey baby,
we don't want those peasants and their animals in the forest anymore.
So they started hiring forest guards.
They started hiring charcoal burners who shoveled?
Yay.
Who are chopping down the trees.
A slicing them up as people still doing this.
Joha are still doing the black forester or do anywhere that you can think of in
Europe.
In my Oregon I where I'm from,
uh,
and uh,
logging was a good way to make money.
He and I,
you know,
when you're,
uh,
I never did it,
but when you're in college,
um,
and so the wood is leaving the forest,
the people are getting even richer and the peasants are idle up.
Why are they out of luck?
Because what the,
the,
the big money people do that own the forest is they do exactly what the wealthy
did.
An England,
the big land owners,
they get the law on their side.
What a surprise.
They have their lobbyists,
they get the law on their side.
They pass a new forest code in 1827
that keeps basically ordinary people out of the forest to which they had always
had access.
They had always had access.
They can't go there anymore.
They go up there and they find guards,
they're armed guards,
but they are many and the guards are few and they scare the hell out of them and
they drive them away.
They drive them away in the mayors of these little villages.
My sock was,
when I love to go places,
I've written about it.
Uh,
a messiah was one in the mirror.
He's in a difficult position.
He knows damn well who is causing the troubles,
the tube in the forest.
But he's got to live with these people.
So he didn't going to be telling on anybody.
So I followed this through.
I read this and,
and uh,
I wrote,
you know,
something about it and it book I did a long time ago called 1830,
uh,
in,
in France edited book.
So,
um,
what happens,
who is Jean Lieutenant of the demo?
[inaudible] who is she?
Well,
she didn't exist either.
She's exactly like captain swing.
She says we are many.
We are right.
We have justice on our side.
By the way,
these people did not speak French.
So there it was hard for them to find somebody to write in French.
You're your agony.
We'll begin.
Uh,
because they don't speak French.
They spoke,
they spoke Patois.
That's very much influenced by,
by,
by Spanish,
that that's not even really like the,
uh,
like a,
you know,
cut to allow,
uh,
or certainly nothing to do with Bosc,
which has done anything to do with anything except vaguely Hungarian and finish.
Um,
and so they write these things and then they say that gene,
that the tenor of the demo was hell,
we'll toast you one day if you don't leave the forest and what they want.
Of course,
if they want the government to return and restore their rights in the forest,
does the government do that?
Are you kidding?
Of course they don't.
Now 1830 comes along,
revolution,
liberty,
fraternity,
equality,
red,
white,
and blue.
So what do they do?
They say,
well,
what's this liberty must mean that we can ever force back,
doesn't it?
So that,
you know,
but one of the interesting things about this is they become petitioners just for
a little bit.
They get people who can write French to petition saying,
Gee,
we hear about this liberty in Paris and that's surely is our forest,
isn't it?
The government says,
oh no,
no,
the forest code of 1827 is,
is is ever more in,
in,
in use,
and you can't have access to the forest.
And the forest guards return,
the forest guards return to the d to The forest,
but sort of the demos l and they begin to dress up as women again.
They lose what a surprise there driven away.
Why did they dress up as women?
Well,
one thing,
a disguise,
you know,
you,
uh,
one thing they do,
by the way,
the charcoal,
they as her mocking the charcoal workers also,
they put charcoal on their face and they were sheets they tried to look like,
make them look like dresses.
Why is women,
why is women,
it's more than a disguise.
What it is,
is an enraged carnival.
If you think of carnival take of Mardi gras in your anywhere in Europe,
anywhere in,
in Christian Europe,
what you do during carnival,
look at the floats in New Orleans.
Whenever we was getting wasted and dressing up in various things,
the,
the old version of that was that you dressed up like your exploiters.
You could the three days or four days,
you could mock the judge who handed out unfair sentences.
You could mock the big fat noble who had senior or rights over you.
You could muck the John Dharm who treated you thought,
treated you badly.
You could pretend it was,
uh,
it was,
it was a carnival,
but an enraged carnival during carnival.
You stand the world on its head and what you did in this case,
as you dressed up as women reversing reality from their point of view,
and this enraged carnival is intended rather like the,
the shopping environment that should shoot me.
You can call it an English,
uh,
in which you,
you know,
you,
you pound on pots and pans outside.
Uh,
the host of a couple or a woman for example,
is married somebody from another village.
You try to set things right again by pounding on calling attention to a misdeed.
This violated the communal sense of justice.
And that's what these people are doing there.
There were there saying,
respect us,
respect justice.
And so they're dressing up like women.
They're standing in the world on his head and it's an enraged,
deadly serious carnival,
you know,
they'll,
they'll shoot at these people and you know,
beat the hell out of them when they catch them.
And so that's so Zhan the,
the,
the lieutenant of the dumb was l represents justice and this kind of acting out
of this enraged carnival.
So it's more than a disguise,
but they don't,
when captain swing doesn't win,
either they're arrested,
they're put on trial,
some of them are put in the slammer in jail,
but they,
in the end,
uh,
you know,
if they come back in 1830 and of 1830,
1831,
so many,
1832,
if I remember right,
1848,
they're back.
1872 but then never again.
And the,
the Ahi,
she has a department depopulate rapidly in the second half of the 19th century.
These people can't make it in the forest anymore.
They can't go into the forest anymore.
They can't survive with a little plots of land.
And so they bail up,
they get out and their great,
great,
great grandchildren.
Uh,
many of them work in the [inaudible] and the,
you know,
the aircraft,
uh,
factories in,
in,
uh,
in Toulouse,
or go to [inaudible] or go to Paris or ended up go to Azure or end up somewhere
else.
So the dumb was l like captain swing,
like these grain rioters in all of these countries in Spain,
in Britain,
in Prussia,
everywhere.
These are the remnants of what people viewed as a traditional way of doing
things that at least was infused with a sense of the proper,
a sense of popular justice and the demos.
I'll try to stand carnival on in the world,
on its head during carnival and try to get people to do the right thing,
to return the forests to them.
Return the threshing machines,
get the threshing machines the hell out of the big farms and Kant and other
places restored grain and bread to a reasonable price.
So everybody could have a shot at buying some,
but in the end they lose out to this dynamic duo more powerful duel,
the state and capitalism.
It's bitter hard to write the history of remainders.